there's no fear in the eyes of valeria
the five-year-old ukrainian who until
recently had known only joy in her life
with dreams as big as the 45-meter photo
of her unfurled this week in levive
supported literally by dozens of
ukrainians her picture has now become a
symbol for her country's resilience
of course we know now how so many dreams
are being shattered yet within the
nightmare that's unfolding the strength
of the child refugees has been as
heartwarming as it is tragic
the teachers at this german school were
devastated to see how so many kids were
in need of help yet the families
arriving were so thankful so kind it
raised their spirits
this school director says once he saw
the children in the playground he
realized that's exactly what they needed
so they let them play classes could wait
fortunately it takes a lot to extinguish
the innocence in a child but that
doesn't make it any easier for mothers
like elena who escaped to poland her
young son wants to return home but not
before elena gets rid of the monsters
waiting there
if only it were that easy eventually the
truth will find them how can it not the
weight of the war should be on the
adults not kids like the one this senior
citizen in moldova has agreed to shelter
as maria says we're all human beings and
no one reminds us of that like the
littlest ones microlight global news
toronto